As a writer and performer,
for years, I have been known
for giving voice or voices
to the many diverse characters
I play onstage
and, more recently, in my film
“Sell/Buy/Date.”
My characters, these characters,
some of whom you are about to meet,
are based on people from my real life,
including my very real mixed race family.
Like me.
My name is Lorraine. Hi there, TED.
It's wonderful.
I'm kvelling to be here
with you all again.
Thank you for having me.
Please don't AI me.
(Laughter)
So Lorraine is based partly
on a real relative of mine.
But don't worry, I changed the names
to protect the innocent
and especially the guilty.
Claro que sí. Hi, I'm Nereida.
Muy buenas tardes, everybody.
I am also from Sarah Jones's family,
but I'm a little bit nervous
because I was so excited
to come back here to TED,
and then Sarah Jones was like,
"We are going to be talking about
how everyone is afraid of cancel culture."
And I was like, "First of all,
we are here speaking as people
from different backgrounds.
Are we even allowed to do that anymore?
Like what if people confuse
what we're doing
with cultural appropriation,
which is probably the fastest
way to get us all canceled?
Oh, my God. No, thank you.”
As you can hear, my characters
have their own take on things,
but I had a very personal experience
of cancel culture,
and I wanted to share about it here.
And I’m hoping that if we’re willing
to really talk about all of this,
maybe we can stop living in fear of it
and get at what's actually underneath it.
Now you’ve already met
Lorraine and Nereida ...
But you haven’t met me.
Hi, I'm Bella.
She/her pronouns.
I’m a double major,
feminism and philosophy,
and actually social justice.
Just auditing.
(Laughter)
But also I'm minoring in social media
with a concentration
on notable TikTok memes.
(Laughter)
But as far as, like, cancel culture
with, like, older people ...
I mean, like, not to say that,
like, you're all older,
but, like, just some of you
are more, like,
chronologically advanced ...
(Laughter)
people and, like, more successful, right?
So, like, obvi, you have, like,
the most to lose, right?
Um. So --
(Applause)
Bella makes an annoying
but very good point, right?
This is a global phenomenon
with immeasurable impact
on culture, commerce.
And I know, the feeling is
over the past few years,
there has suddenly been this rise
of a terrifying specter
that everybody has to fear.
But in my experience,
cancel culture
actually hasn't been sudden,
and it is certainly not new.
If the definition of being canceled
is being silenced, excluded,
disempowered and disinvited
from the larger conversation,
then for many of us,
cancel culture has defined our lives
for most of history.
I mean, spoiler alert, I'm Black.
Also a woman.
I have Latino relatives.
I'm even a little part Jewish.
I know what it is to have cancellation
baked into who I am.
So some of our experiences
down through history
have amounted
to a kind of pre-cancellation.
It's only now that this
new kind of cancellation
has begun to impact
the powerful and dominant
with the pre-canceled folk saying,
"Hey, this system has been failing
a lot of us for centuries.
So now it's our turn.
We're going to take justice
into our own hands
and cancel you."
And I agree that we need the equity
and justice our laws promise
but often don't deliver.
For example, harmful
and even criminal behavior,
when committed by powerful people,
has often gone completely unpunished.
And in situations like that, yeah,
cancel culture can at least offer
some form of restitution.
Now that said, as a system,
it's far from perfect.
I mean, once people are canceled,
how are we actually
holding them accountable?
Like there are those creepy comedians
or CEOs who might have to hole up
in their mansions for a little while.
But before you know it, a lot of them
are right back in Madison Square Garden
or otherwise in business.
And meanwhile, the larger systems
that created them keep right on going.
Now even worse, sometimes people
who are the opposite
of the Harvey Weinsteins of the world
can get lumped in and dragged
as soon as one voice screams
“cancellation” in a crowded theater.
I mentioned my film
"Sell/Buy/Date" earlier.
It was inspired by a play
of the same name.
I even performed an early excerpt
of it right here at TED.
And it’s a one-person show that explores
themes of women and sex and power
through the lens of the sex industry.
But if you don't know my work,
let me give you a little bit more context.
Since I grew up watching
racial, ethnic and other stereotypes,
or no images of us at all,
my work has always been
about accurately portraying people
in our full humanity.
And in the case of "Sell/Buy/Date,"
which was inspired by real people
in the sex industry
whom I had spent years getting to know
and who generously trusted me
with their stories onstage,
I was grateful my work was received
as a loving tribute
to those diverse people and ideas.
That is, until the film version
was announced in the press.
The film was backed by a team
of A-list Hollywood producers.
And so suddenly
this was a much bigger platform.
And people who did not know me
and my connection to the topic
assumed I was a cultural appropriator
with bad intentions,
and suddenly I was under brutal attack.
I mean, strangers
from all over the internet
were coming for me personally,
threatening my funders,
promising to cancel anyone
associated with my film.
Why?
Well, these cancelers were
actually concerned sex workers.
They were afraid my film
would be disrespectful
to the already very marginalized people
in the sex industry.
And I get that.
But before I could even make the film
and include the voices of sex workers,
as I had always planned,
they said I had no right to tell my story
since I'm not in the industry myself.
And they were more than willing
to destroy me and my career.
Ultimately, I hung in there.
I made the film, which shows me
wrestling with these issues,
and it was critically acclaimed
by the “New York Times.”
But along the way,
I, the film and the very people
it was trying to serve
all suffered harm
that may never be undone.
I've lost friendships and opportunities
that can never be restored.
But even worse, the distraction
of the cancellation
pulled focus from the goal
of destigmatizing people
in the sex industry.
And that is another huge problem
with cancel culture,
is that at its worst it can end up
hurting the very people
it's trying to help.
And even at its best,
it can still fuel
this continuous loop of fear.
Like there are the marginalized folks
who fear very understandably
that they'll be disempowered yet again.
And then there are the people
who are in power
and fear losing that power.
Or they secretly feel
like they're being indicted
rather than invited into a conversation.
And nobody is really evolving
under circumstances like that.
Meanwhile, the larger culture
of inequality not only isn't improving,
it's actually getting worse out here
because everybody's just reacting
from their amygdala.
So ...
What's the solution?
Well, kind of like with my film,
I'm not here to tell you
what you have to think.
Yes, but I will listen.
Even the nice Black girl is saying
cancel culture is not the solution.
So I think we should all just say,
"Poo poo poo. Glad we cleared that up.
We can all move on, thank God."
Yeah, well --
Yes but, Lorraine, it’s not that simple
because many of us, you know,
the pre-canceled people,
we can't just move on
without a more equitable,
a better society.
The good news is,
I believe that starts less
with looking at Twitter
and more with, well,
looking at the man in the mirror.
At the risk of invoking
a very canceled pop icon, I'm sorry.
Research shows that if we try
looking really honestly at ourselves
and any biases or privilege we may have,
it could actually improve
our quality of life.
A recent piece in "Scientific American"
about unlearning certain prejudices
pointed to research that --
wait for this --
even with power,
when the dominant group
fears losing that power,
they are more anxious,
more angry, defensive, paternalistic,
which harms us all.
So whether we're the ones
who fear being canceled
or we're trying to hold others to account,
we can all start a daily practice
of being self-accountable.
To notice, without judgment,
any tendencies in ourselves
that could be hurtful to others.
And I'm not saying
that unlearning our biases
will automatically
shield us from cancellation,
but we can at least try to own
any mistakes we might be making.
And we don’t have to do it alone.
We can surround ourselves
with trusted people
who may be more aware
of certain issues than we are.
Think of them as
your own personal cancel counsel.
(Laughter)
Yeah? OK.
Lastly, let’s say we’re the ones
doing the canceling.
Looking honestly at ourselves
can keep us from automatically assuming
the worst in people
who could be well-meaning.
Now I know, I know. Don’t @ me.
A lot of these people out here
getting canceled do not mean well.
Or even if they do,
good intentions might not help much
when a stranger asks
if they can touch your hair.
I mean, unless that stranger
is Jason Momoa.
Just saying.
(Laughter)
He has my consent.
But the point is,
we don't just want to ignore
thoughtless missteps or worse.
But I do believe even alongside
the painful inequities,
we are still mostly just people
who are trying to do the right thing.
And if we are falling short of that,
banishment alone doesn't
actually solve the problem.
It just creates
more hurt and angry people.
Now, I'm hoping that without pretending
this is an even playing field,
that we can still empathize
with each other just a little bit more.
Maybe you can even become
the cancel counsel to someone
you would otherwise have written off.
Invite them to share
where they were trying to come from,
and then show them any biases
they might have been blind to.
I'm not saying it's easy.
I know a lot of us are really tired,
but I also think we would be amazed
at how connecting to someone on that level
could take a hurtful event
and turn it into a chance
for healing and real progress.
Now, listen, I'm --
I'm not saying any of us
will ever be perfect,
but maybe we can try
to give each other and ourselves
the grace of assuming good intentions
while still doing the work
that acknowledges how far we have to go.
Thank you.
(Applause)